hey guys Ryan Reich sitting here and
sitting here is Brandi yes she is
anyway guys we're gonna check out the
trailer today for true detective season
2 I hear it stars Colin Farrell and
Vincent bond me too very fast talking
people I'm very excited to see this show
and see if I can keep up with what
they're saying
Broken Bow
inside circle
fighting
ooh chills yeah really good erect
nipples I just gotta say HBO they have
like the best commercials reveal
anything but it still looks really me oh
it shows you the tone and the darkness
of it I'm excited for it mainly for the
performances I mean I'm that's what
people were really excited for for
season one to see Woody Harrelson and
Matthew McConaughey for a whole
miniseries and I'm excited to see this
for like okay Colin Farrell yes we know
he can do this like he's proven time and
time again that he can do roles like
this but then you also got Rachel
McAdams who I've never seen in a role
like this I haven't seen anything like
this either but she's just so awesome
she's a great actress she's one of my
favorites yeah she's beautiful look at
and you also get like a tough cider her
this time you know like I think about
when Amy Adams did the fighter like I
think so watching her in this wielding a
gun like doubt she looks like she's
really gonna pull it off and the other
thing that I always get jacked for this
when a comedian who has shown that they
could do drama goes back to drama again
Vince Vaughn oh yeah so it's cool to see
Vince Vaughn going back to like some
serious yeah there used to be more
character stuff yeah psycho Oh was he in
psycho play Norman Bates oh my gosh is a
really good movie good remake best
remake of all time I don't think I've
seen it yeah it's not worth anyone's
time yeah I'm excited for it for all
those purposes just to see these actors
come together it's cool because you know
like now we got three big actors in this
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and you can check out brand new prices
channel covers a lot of indie stuff
check it out and she does a lot of
trailer reactions too and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
well we're always like what's up people
retweet my post because we're trying to
get more followers why because if we get
a certain amount of followers
product placement people product I take
the approach of honesty you know people
try to get more followers for other
things
I'm being straightforward product
placement I want to be able to tweet
something and get like $100,000 out of
it that would be pretty nice
maybe my range is a little too high
maybe